[Music]
hey i'm dave klein i'm phil hornshaw and
we just had the chance to check out
cuphead the dlc that's coming out soon
yes delicious last course yeah so what
were your thoughts uh i had a great time
with it it was very difficult as
difficult as you expect cuffed head to
be uh despite the fact that you get like
you know a few little certain things to
help you along like when you play with
this new character that's a big part of
the dlc that's miss chalice that's like
the big hook of delicious last course
and she gets like one extra little
health thing she has a double jump but
it really instead of feeling it feels
like it could have been easier but it's
not it's really just different
and uh i was not prepared for that i had
played a little extra cuphead to get
here so i wouldn't be embarrassed on the
show floor and that was not the case
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i found that miss chalice it's just
different it doesn't make it easier um
a big change with miss chalice is that
she has a double jump right but because
she has a double jump now your parry
isn't by double by hitting that jump
button again which as it was in the
normal game or which dlc as well if you
play as mug man or cuphead right um now
instead your dash is going to be how you
do that perry move which throws things
off a completely different part of your
brain feels like right yeah i'm not sure
honestly if i like it as much it was
cool having a double jump but i feel
like i might go right back to cuphead
myself yeah and that's definitely a
thing that is viable about this which is
cool like um the dlc adds a lot of new
content it's a whole new island bigger
than any of the other islands in the
game yeah but you also can take miss
chalice back and play the rest of the
game
with that character in those new moves
or you can obviously you can play from
the beginning of the new dlc as the old
characters so like you can kind of mix
and match uh decide how you want to deal
with different challenges that sort of
thing yep so what we specifically got to
play was the boss that they've shown
already which is the wizard who turns
into an abominable snowman and then a
giant flake we played as miss chalice
and uh she had the spreadshot and homing
shot that we could bounce between the
one specific thing that was definitely
new was her
super x attack which was like a vertical
beam
and uh for the specific boss it did not
come in handy whatsoever but i could see
sort of more vertical bass boss as it
being a really good option because in
the normal game you have the like
horizontal version of the same thing
that really comes in handy so it's a
cool option just one that
was not helpful in this very specific
situation indeed yeah i found that like
for myself i thought the boss was pretty
on par um
with maybe like early world three bosses
i'd say
um yeah yeah that typical like three
stages it evolves over time yeah and
like a whole new thing you gotta learn
every time you get to a new spot
yeah but i mean it felt great just like
cuphead always does uh
personally i'm really excited about just
because i love cuphead more cup is a
good thing yeah i'm really interested in
the way the dlc is going to like rework
the game a little bit um having this
chalice as a different means of going
through old content seems like really
interesting and like having um talk to
the developers a little bit like
yeah the idea was they wanted to make
something that was complementary without
being it wasn't they didn't want it just
to be new or more they wanted to be
something like that feels different it's
a little bit of a different take so fans
have something new to work with so
in a big way it feels like it could kind
of like re refresh the
original game a little more yeah what's
kind of amazing was it sounds like it's
just as much content when i was talking
to them at least just as much animation
frames if not more animation than the
original game yeah it's a huge amount of
animation
and actually like where the the original
game was like 1930s disney stuff this is
you know still in that same area but
kind of moving a little forward kind of
getting closer to like fantasia 1940s
not you know not outside of the realm or
different from what we saw in cuphead
originally but kind of moving it forward
a little bit adding a little more
influences to uh what we're seeing there
yeah i guess uh if you like cuphead this
is more the same it's gonna be you're
gonna like it if you don't like cuphead
it's more the same you're probably not
gonna like it well you know i do think
miss chalice might be a bit of an
on-ramp for people who had a hard time
with cuphead maybe bounced off yeah i
guess that double jump double jump yeah
extra health you know i think you can
tune a little bit you don't does she
automatically have that extra health it
comes with four i know that's not true
but i wasn't sure if it because you know
the original game you have that bonus
you can give yourself the extra health
or extra two health right you attack for
less so i wasn't sure if that was just
equipped and i didn't know what was
equipped and to get miss chalice you
give up your charm
oh insurance so that's that's the upshot
right like you get double jump you get
the extra health but it takes a charm to
become miss chalice and so you don't
have that that option yeah she also has
like uh i think it has iframes a dash
move that she can do right i didn't use
it uh just because i guess i didn't need
it well you've got to like relearn the
game yeah i think it's like
re-learning i didn't take too long with
it though so there's no i know what
it was impressive nice work we both beat
it yeah i did beat it
um
yeah like i feel like the honestly the
challenge is on par with
three at least the specific boss so um
hopefully that means like it's like the
next island basically would be i guess
in terms of the difficulty the challenge
i'm guessing that's what they're going
for i'm really interested to see how it
like fits where how it feels as you're
ramping in if it like starts back down
slow again i mean it's been five years
we might all need a little minute to
like get used to cuphead again yeah
we're gonna have a little spud boss yeah
right are you gonna like i don't know if
you're gonna bounce straight into like
full challenge or not i'm interested to
see how that works it sounds like
there's enough content in here that
there might be a chance to kind of like
bury it out a little bit
give you a chance to get your feet back
all right so cuphead releases june the
30th and hey as a big fan of cuphead i'm
looking forward to it
yeah so hey stay tuned the game spot for
all things summer game fest and we'll
see you guys soon bye
[Music]
you